Hey guys, welcome to a brand new video.
Today I'm going to be going over another
five shops that are very OP to buy from
in Old School Runescape. Again, shops
are really good if you don't have a lot
of money, if you don't have that high of
skills, they're very good for making
some entry-level money, and we're going
to go have a look at another five of
them. All right, let's get started.
Okay, so for the first method, uh you'll
actually need access to the
Culinaromancer's Chest, so you will need
uh certain degree of Recipe for Disaster
completed. However, uh the benefit here
is the bank is literally the same chest
that you are buying items from, which is
pretty convenient. What you're going to
be buying is the grapes, cuz if we have
a look at the value, as of only one GP
from the shop, and notably 266 on the
Grand Exchange, so you can go ahead buy
10,
go down here, hop to another world, and
not a lot of people are doing this, and
plus there is a bit of a requirement to
get access to this, so it's not usually
contested. And you just have to hop
three times, and you get a full
inventory. Now, currently a full
inventory is worth somewhere between 7
and 8K, which is actually quite good,
especially considering that this
requires no money to start doing. One GP
per grape is nothing. So, from 28 GP, we
just turned that into 7.3K just like
that, and grapes sell really quickly as
well. Uh so, we'll do this for a little
bit just to see what the GP per hour
would look like, and we'll be back after
maybe 5 or 10 minutes. Okay, so we did
this for about 5 minutes, and I was able
to get eight inventory of grapes, uh
which equals 216 of them. Uh so, let's
go ahead and give that a price check.
216 is equal to about 58K.
Uh so, if we calculate that per hour,
it's equal to about 700K an hour, which
is very good. Uh super easy, especially
if you get wiped or you have no money.
700K from scratch is amazing. You do
have to be worried about uh getting
booted out from switching worlds too
much, though, because there isn't much
downtime, so Did have to kind of stop
for a minute every in a while? Next up
we have the magic guild in Dondinel. Uh
now on the second level there is
a stall essentially that you can buy
battle staves from as well as death
runes.
Uh now the main drawback here is it is
heavily botted uh due to its low
requirement. All you need is 60 magic to
get in here.
Besides that you're good. So there's
tons of people here that you can be
fighting over the items for, but like I
said, low requirement and uh pretty
decent profit. I mean each battle staff
is a 1K profit. That's not the right
one. Uh death runes can be bought down
to zero while still profiting. If we
have a look here, examine the death
rune,
uh 246 on the GE and in the shop is 219.
So you can buy them all the way down to
zero. And uh battle staves, buy those as
well. So it's actually pretty
profitable. Um now my guess would be
because of the bots you're probably not
going to get more than 6 or 700K an hour
here. However, if they weren't here, you
could probably break one to one and a
half mil an hour just because of how
profitable the death runes are from
buying them. But you're never going to
get that. Okay, so next step is uh the
karambwan method. And now to do this you
will need to have completed Tai Bwo
Wannai trio as well as you will need to
acquire some trading sticks. Now they
can be bought on the Grand Exchange for
about 12 GP each and that's what I've
done.
Uh so what we're going to be doing is
buying karambwans from Ti Adeish.
Uh so they have 10 in stock. Now if you
look at the value here, um
they're 110 from the shop and 583
on the Grand Exchange. It's a very good
margin. However, uh it's going to cost
an extra 180 to send them from here,
which I believe is still quicker than
running back and what that's what I did
in one of my other videos. So it's
usually not too busy here. Look, we got
no problem, full inventory. There we go.
So now what you do is there's a man a
little bit north of the village who will
actually send uh your items to a bank in
exchange for trading sticks.
He should be just up here. This guy,
Reenasta. Send parcel. Once it's open,
you just right click on the Karamwan,
pack all, and they've been successfully
sent to the bank at a cost of 260
trading sticks,
uh, which is about uh, 300 GP. Okay, so
if you're really on it and there's
nobody here competing with you, you can
do a boat in inventory every minute.
However, if it's not topped out in every
world, probably do uh, four every five
minutes. But let's just say you can do
one every minute cuz it is possible. And
on each Karamwan, we're getting 326, uh,
GP in profit. I calculated that by
taking
the average we're selling them for,
which is 484, minus how much we're
buying them for, 138, minus also 120 GP
per Karamwan for the trading stick cost.
So, 326. So, per inventory, we are
getting 8,476k.
You do an inventory every minute, so
times 60 is about 500k an hour, uh,
which is not too bad. However, uh, when
the, uh, Karamwan buff essentially came
out, uh, with the make all update, you
were actually able to get about 700-800k
an hour. But still pretty good and Tai
Bwo Wannai Trio is not a top requirement
to get, so it's actually very accessible
to most people. Now, next up is actually
an archery store. I'm at Hickin's
Archery Emporium in Catherby. Uh,
there's no requirements to do this. You
just need a little bit of money.
Uh, if we have a look at the prices
here, there's actually quite a few
profitable items here. Mainly the arrow
tips.
Uh, so they sell for 200 and on the GE,
they're selling for 232.
You do have to watch out though after
buying some out, uh, it is the price
will go up fairly quickly. So, like you
can only really buy 15 of those. Adamant
bolt tips, uh, 81 and they sell for 97
on the GE. Now, I'm not sure if this
world's been bought into it all.
Mithrils, uh, 32 GP into 49. Now, this
really is dependent on how quickly you
can click. So, it's not my favorite
method, but it's actually very good
considering that has no requirements at
all, and you can buy them down
reasonably low. Now, we'll go and hop
worlds. Now, I don't expect a lot of
other people are doing this. However,
uh, it doesn't seem like the shops are
maxed out, either. Uh, so, I think if
you do this at an off-peak hour, you may
actually get some decent profit from
these items. And again, no, uh,
requirements for this, but I probably
wouldn't imagine getting more than two
or three hundred K an hour. So, it's
probably not my first-rated one, but
still an option if you have, uh, no
quests and just a bit of money. And the
last method I'm going to show you today
is actually unique in the way that's on
Zeah. Uh, what we're going to be doing
is buying sandworm packs from Tyras'
fishing supply store. Now, this is
located just in the northeast segment of
the Piscarilius house. Uh, if you come
to Zeah, you'd be coming in right here.
And it's just kind of the northeast
segment there. Uh, what we're going to
be buying is sandworm packs. Now,
they're kind of pricey. They're 9K each.
However, you're buying 100 sandworms.
Now, uh, sandworms actually sell for
about 100 on the Grand Exchange. Let's
go and look it up on GE Tracker here.
Uh, routinely sell for 100. So, in each
pack, you can make upwards of 1K in
profit. Even after five packs, it brings
it down to a 500 GP profit. But, look
how quickly it actually restocks itself.
So, you can actually make a ton of money
here. So, we'll go ahead and test this
out for a little bit. Uh, another one
drawback here is you actually require a
ton of starting capital to actually do
this method. While the sandworms
actually sell off reasonably quickly,
you do need quite a bit of money cuz
each pack is worth,
uh, 9K each. That's 45K every time
you're coming in here. So, to do this
for an hour, you'd need probably like 10
to 15 mil. However, just doing it for 15
minutes, you'd only need two or three
mil or something like that. Okay, so
we're back. In about five minutes, we
were able to buy about 11,000
of the sandworms. Now, the average price
we bought them at was about 91.8
and we're selling them on the GE for 100
each.
Of course, I can vary and you do want to
check the prices ahead of time, but 100
- 91.8
is a 8.2 profit per sandworm. If we
multiply that by 11,200, that means we
profited 91k in 5 minutes. Times that by
12 and you're looking at actually at
over a mill an hour. Now, you have to
take this with a grain of salt.
Sandworms are going to sell on the Grand
Exchange about
ideally 8,000 an hour.
So, you really don't want to do this for
too long because the sell rate is just
not going to match how quickly you can
buy them. You want to make sure you're
selling them for at least like 95 or 96,
although 100 would be ideal. But, you
can see the potential here is very good
for making a ton of money, especially
considering that there are no
requirements to come here.
The main drawback is the amount of
starting capital that you do require.
But, I think it's a good method anyway.
All right, guys, that's about it. So,
there's another five shops you can buy
from in Old School Runescape to make
some pretty decent bank. And yeah, hope
you enjoyed the video. If you did, don't
forget to toss it a like and I'll see
you in the next one.